I may look like a nice English lady in a sensible cardigan, but these days it's a thin veneer and it's starting to crack
Who wants to bring kids into this bloody world? My point is I just don't think that the world needs more kids
I think we get it
Tucker Crowe, one of the most unsung figures of alternative rock. Hasn't been seen in 20 years. That's him
Wow, he's so gorgeous. Thank you
I think I've had enough Tucker bloody Crowes to last 20 lifetimes
Tucker has a new album and I don't want to spend my time with someone who doesn't get it
Oh, somebody new. "Juliet Naked is a naked attempt to squeeze a few more quid out of a long-dead career"
You wrote this
There's the strangest thing. I met someone on the Internet. You're finally entering the modern age.
He read that review I posted
"You nailed it. I couldn't have explained it better myself" -Tucker Crowe
Tucker Crowe? As in Duncan's idol Tucker Crowe? Yes
"Yeah, it's really me. What's your story?"
Dear Tucker, it's really odd to be saying all this to a stranger, but I have a hunch I've wasted the last 15 years of my life
I don't imagine this as much of a consolation, but I'm ashamed to say that two decades have slipped through my fingers
At least you have a past to live up to
Big news. I'm coming to London. Would you like to meet for a drink?
Beautiful spot
You're not downstairs, are you?
That's me in my high school chess club. I can explain this. I'm not trying to trap, or cut your head off or whatever
Hey! How've you been?
Duncan Thompson. Tucker Crowe. I'm Stevie Wonder. Just take it easy. Real mature, honey
What are you drinking Tucker Crowe? Glass of water. I'm not getting a famous American rock star a glass of water
I'm not that famous of okay, and I'm an alcoholic. Well, you'll fit right in
I was wondering if you'd be interested in me? Do you think there's any way back for me?
You sure this doesn't have something to do with your idol coming along and fancying me?
Please, how do we know that's even him? Well, I have a passport.  Well, that would be super
Well, all of this seems to be in order. Really? Oh thank god